hi I want to first thank you for all
that you do for everybody I really
appreciate it thank you
I've met you a couple of times in Idaho
I remember yeah let me tell you a quick
story if I may because you know I
appreciate the kind words and I was at
the home office a couple of days ago and
there is all these nuns from Mexico had
come over to buy product and take back
into Mexico you know sometimes there's
five or six or dozen or so and they all
happen hug me kiss me these are Catholic
nuns and they all run up and hug me and
kiss me they say well what do you what
do you nuns why are you so excited here
I've seen you many many times why are
you so excited now
he said the peasants from the mountains
of Mexico have heard of the youngevity
products he'll and they're coming to our
churches now by the hundreds every day
to get the youngevity products to heal
themselves and families so the word is
getting out we thank you for your part
and doing that
janie thank you so much yeah well I just
wanted to let you know I'm 75 years old
I'm 115 pounds 5:3 I've been taking your
products since 1993 when you were with
soaring eagle yes and came out yes I
don't take any prescription medicine or
anything and I follow the diet and I
have malabsorption and I I've got a
problem with extreme dryness belly
dryness can reach a vaginal dryness go
to talk about everything is dry okay
Charmaine in a week you're gonna turn 75
just like Janie yep they're working with
these for a gosh well almost 26 years
now 27 years 27 years Wow okay so what
would you do because you know your skin
looks great for a 75 year old person and
what would you do what would advice
would you give her for something to put
on her skin and also what would you give
her for the female drivers well for
those issues dry skin usually is a lack
of essential fatty acid
so I would increase my EFA s and that
okay that should and what would you put
on topically what would be your favorite
put on topically just to put on her skin
as a skin moisturizer I like so purpose
myself well there you go
so purpose exactly and of course it's
from the shade nuts from western Africa
it's not an oil is called shea butter
and it's one of the few skin moisturizer
that don't have oil in it it's actually
a butter that comes from a nuts a big
seed kind of like an avocado seed and
and you which one you like of the sole
purpose ones brown sugar brown sugar
yeah brown sugar and honey yeah okay
yeah I'll use that as an aftershave when
it's cold weather I'll use that too yeah
okay say rate and then what would you
use for the female stuff oh the Zira
film zero film at 115 pounds I never
take two of those tablets twice a day
made two bottles a month of the zero
film and then what would you give her in
a liquid form a herbal thing goes back
to 1833 how about woman's FX that's what
I just said woman's effect I didn't hear
that
sorry I said that woman's effects yes
okay yeah I didn't hear that I heard
there's there a family there the sounds
effects okay so yeah woman's FX I'd go
ahead Jani go ahead and take an ounce
twice a day sounds twice today it'll be
two quarts a month and as things improve
and get to where you like it to be then
you kind of cut back and do a half of
those things just for maintenance and we
have so many wonderful wonderful things
for beauty and the skincare for both men
and women it's just amazing the things
that we can do now